Dinwiddie crosses eight seconds fighters  delivers a three  122 119 a lot of room a great screen by  Jared Dudley the guns will allow Reggie  Jackson to get out to him picking up Joe  Harris I should say bumping Jackson up  there in right on line  the question has been shoving it off the  three-point line but he's got a lot of  room a great screen by Jared Dudley ball  down the stretch of the game he's got  Andre Drummond on him has got room step  back  he has been knocking down three point  shots with a great level of comfort and  here's a situation where the neces at  times been stagnant on offense  throughout this overtime period that's  exactly the type of look with the timing